how many ways are there of a selecting
be arranging three letters of the word
algebra okay
so the first one is selecting and then
the second one is arranging so obviously
one order matters and one disorder
doesn't okay now yeah the way we with
employers look there are seven letters
right you want three so it's going to
have something to do with seven choose
three or seven pick three or something
like that
except if you don't get the right
answers and the question is why and
that's why I always headed out panting
columns because like all what I'm going
to see let's find a B isn't it right you
can notice that one of the problems will
be okay you've got these two A's right
so that repetition causes you issues
that's what makes this a tricky question
okay but simply divide by two turns out
to be not a very useful approach because
I think which one is it one of these is
an odd number so you divide by two and
you get a half of a way so it's like
it's kind of a way but it's not a very
good one like what they mean so here's
the way that I would go about it now I
make sure I do in the right order
okay when you're selecting so I don't
care about which order I get them in
okay you gotta make sure be careful with
these age okay so here's the way that I
would think about it there are three
basic ways you can make a three-letter
word and what I'm going to do is because
the A's are the problem I'm going to
take them out of the equation as a
variable so I'm going to think about the
three ways as here's one way method
number one I could have no age okay
so just forget about the fact that there
is for a second that means I've got five
different letters to chitra l/d b ah
right so how many ways are there to make
a three-letter word when I've gotten two
A's to choose from and so remember I'm
not care about order right so here's a
see up here it's see that's exactly
right if I don't care about water I've
got five to choose from
and I've got to choose three of them
okay it's @array all right now the
second way is what if I have just one
eighth okay I don't forget like I don't
care where the eight years right it
could be the start or a middle at the
end if I've already chosen the a I've
got to make the other two that is from
one of these five right and again don't
care what order right so I still have
five to choose from but I'm not choosing
three I'm choosing to right okay last
way the third method is what if I use
both eight okay so I could have them at
the ends or I could have them bunched on
the start or bunched at the end okay but
whichever way remember the old Kara
order I have to pick one more letter to
fill it out and have to choose from five
so it's five choose one okay so when you
add when you add all of them um I think
you get to move up this will be five
this is 10 and this is ten as well the
other thing that's the way it works okay
so there's your 25 which is the answer
okay all right now how then do you go
about it when you think about when order
matters okay you've still got to do a
similar thing here right now let me make
sure I read this properly so um I think
the first way I thought about it was um
forget about the fact that I've got a
double up eh
okay so I've got a now B okay now for
what it matters now right so that's
where I'm going to put together my box
okay so in this scenario here this is
just six p4 right six by five by four
six factorial on on on on
I'm three folds all right Victoria yeah
okay
so there's going to be one of your
options however obviously I've
eliminated the possibility here of
having two A's which I can write I can
totally have that now how many ways are
there to have two A's in there okay I
could have the two A's bunched at the
front and then who knows what the
unknown is I could have the A's
separated and there's the unknown or I
could have the a at the end okay now
when you do these these are the same as
this scenario right this is the two A's
okay but now that automat is these three
are all different there are five ways of
doing this one five ways it on that one
five reason doing this one okay now I
think 64 is 100 that looks like under-20
to me there are five here so for each
one that's 15 so your answer is 135 okay
but you see how like it's this is why
it's a good personal question because
it's such a simple setup but you can't
just chuck it into a formula you must
think about how it fits together okay so
yeah everything you kept on okay